lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
mostrar que la multiplicación entre
matrices es asociativa y bueno por lo
menos lo voy a demostrar para matrices
de 2 por 2 aunque en realidad todo lo
que vamos a hacer se puede extender para
matrices de cualquier dimensión siempre
y cuando la multiplicación entre estas
matrices esté bien definida entonces
vamos a poner por aquí dos matrices
tenemos aquí a la matriz
de se dé
y luego tenemos aquí otra matriz
efe
h
y la última matriz
aunque está ahí no es el número
imaginario raíz de menos 1 es
simplemente un número al igual que este
no es el número es simplemente una e
aunque hay una variable entonces esta
matriz es i j k l
y bueno vamos a tener dos casos entonces
déjame copio y pego todo esto y lo
colocamos por acá entonces lo que vamos
a hacer en este caso es multiplicar
primero la matriz naranja con la matriz
amarilla hacer esta multiplicación y
después multiplicar lo que nos quede por
la matriz morada y en este caso vamos a
hacer algo muy similar pero primero
vamos a multiplicar la matriz amarilla
con la matriz morada vamos a hacer esta
multiplicación y lo que nos quede lo
vamos a multiplicar por la matriz
naranja y si lo que nos queda de estos
dos productos es igual entonces
habríamos demostrado que la
multiplicación de matrices por lo menos
de matrices de 2 por 2 si es asociativa
y bueno ya vimos que la multiplicación
entre matrices no es conmutativa y
ahorita pues vamos a ver si si es
asociativa te recomiendo que le pongas
pausa el vídeo y trates de resolverlo tú
solito y luego regresas a ver cómo lo
resuelvo yo
pero bueno te digo desde ahorita que la
multiplicación de matrices si es
asociativa pero hay que demostrarlo paso
por paso entonces vamos a empezar
multiplicando estas dos matrices y
tenemos aquí que nos va a quedar una
matriz de 2 por 2 pero voy a dejar este
paréntesis abierto porque van a hacer
muchas letras en cada entrada entonces
todavía no voy a cerrar la matriz pero
bueno esta entrada es esta fila por esta
columna y entonces nos queda
más de que la segunda entrada es esta
fila por esta columna y nos queda a efe
más de h esta entrada es esta fila por
esta columna y nos queda es
más de g
y finalmente esta fila por esta columna
que es c efe más de h ok esto es la
matriz que nos queda de multiplicar
estas dos matrices y ahora lo que vamos
a hacer es multiplicar la multiplicación
de estas dos matrices por esta otra
matriz ya la copia y la pegué y la
ponemos por aquí y ahora vamos a
multiplicar estas dos matrices nos queda
a ver la primera entrada es esta fila
por esta columna entonces tenemos que
multiplicar la y por todo esto de aquí
nada más que déjame de una vez
distribuyó la y dentro de esta suma y
nos queda y a
más
y por ver por qué más y ahora lo que nos
queda de multiplicar esta entrada porque
aunque porque estamos haciendo esta fila
por esta columna
aquí tenemos y por esta entrada y nos
falta que por esta entrada y nos queda
acá por a por f más que por b por h
y ahora vamos con esta entrada que está
en la primera fila y segunda columna
entonces tenemos que multiplicar esta
primera fila por esta segunda columna y
lo que nos queda es j por todo esto más
l por todo esto porque entonces vamos a
escribirlo jota por apure más jota por
ver porque no está por ver por qué más
l ahora por efe l por a por efe mas l
por b por h o por b por h bueno y
entonces vemos con esta entrada que está
en la segunda fila y primera columna
entonces tomamos la segunda fila y la
multiplicamos por la primera columna nos
queda y por todo esto ósea y por porsche
más y por d por g más acá por todo esto
de aquí o sea que porsche por efe mas k
por d por h listo ya ahora vamos con la
última entrada que está en la segunda
fila segunda columna o sea que vamos a
multiplicar segunda fila por segunda
columna entonces es jota por todo esto
entonces obtenemos jota por porsche más
por de por qué más
por todo esto o sea el porsche por efe
mas l por d
por h y listo el único problema es que
nos estamos acabando este espacio
entonces vamos a hacerla un poquito más
pequeña bueno entonces esta matriz es el
resultado de multiplicar estas tres
matrices con este orden donde primero
multiplicamos la matriz naranja y la
amarilla que es lo que nos indica este
paréntesis y después multiplicamos por
la matriz morada y ahora vamos a
multiplicar estas tres matrices pero con
este otro orden donde el primero
multiplicamos la matriz amarilla con la
morada y después multiplicamos por la
naranja entonces vamos a empezar
multiplicando estas dos matrices
la primera entrada aquí es esta fila por
esta columna
entonces nos queda y por el más
efe por acá la segunda entrada es esta
fila por esta columna y nos queda
j + l
efe esta entrada de aquí es esta fila
por esta columna entonces es ig más acá
por h y esta entrada de aquí es esta
fila por esta columna así es que nos
queda
gj más h por l
ya multiplicamos estas dos matrices y
ahora su producto lo tenemos que
multiplicar por la matriz abc de a b c y
vamos a poner esa matriz ahora qué
la primera entrada resulta de explicar
esta fila con esta columna entonces
tenemos que multiplicar
por todo esto de aquí más b por todo
esto de aquí y de una vez vamos a usar
la propiedad distributiva y nos queda
simplemente a x y por e más a por efe
porque a por efe por k mas ve por esta
cosa de aquí que es b por i por g más b
por acá por h mono y para obtener esta
entrada tenemos que multiplicar esta
fila por esta columna y nos queda se por
y por y más se por efe porque más eso sé
por todo esto de aquí más d por todo
esto de aquí que es de x y por g más de
por acá por h
y ahora vamos a multiplicar esta fila
con esta columna y nos queda apure por
jota más a por él o por efe a por l por
efe mas b porque por j b por g por jota
más b por h por el b por h por el y
finalmente esta fila por esta columna y
nos queda ce por e
por j más c por l por efe mas d por todo
esto de aquí que es de por g por j más
de por h por l y listo ya terminamos de
multiplicar estas tres matrices
multiplicando primero estas dos y
después esta entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es ver si estas dos matrices son
iguales bueno y para ver eso tenemos que
ver que sean iguales entrada por entrada
o sea que todo esto sea igual a todo
o esto vamos a ver tenemos aquí
y por aquí tenemos a él y sabemos que
estas dos cosas son iguales porque estos
ya son simplemente escalares y los
escalares si son conmutativo entonces y
si es igual a a y bueno pero eso es nada
más un elemento de la suma también
tenemos que ver si hay un eje por acá y
pues hasta aquí el eje que son iguales
acá
efe es igual a efe que y cabe h es igual
a bk h entonces esta entrada si es
exactamente igual a esta entrada pero
nos falta ver que eso suceda en todas
estas entradas así es que vamos a ver j
eh
j&j vejez pgj el a efe a él
efe aquí se me fue un error de dedo
tenemos aquí nada más un ave h y aquí
tenemos un b h l pero a ver antes de
tirar todo nuestro trabajo en la basura
tenemos que ver qué pasó en esta entrada
o sea porque no puede ser que nada más
tengamos dos letras por aquí entonces a
ver esta entrada salió de multiplicar la
primera fila con la segunda columna
entonces teníamos que multiplicar j
por todo esto más l por todo esto
keiko está por todo esto está aquí muy
bien pero a la hora de multiplicar l por
todo esto se me pasó ponerle aquí la l
ya tenemos el epp ahora por efe que ya
está el epp ahora por efe
pero luego tenía yo que poner el porve
por h
y nada más puse vih entonces aquí va una
y ahora si el por ver por h es igual a b
por h por l bueno en esta entrada
tenemos y por el porsche sé por y porque
y de g
le dije
casi efe cf que cada h de acá h y luego
las últimas dos entradas tenemos l de h
de h l l c efe cl efe jd g de g j
y finalmente j s c j
entonces estas dos matrices son
exactamente iguales entrada por entrada
y eso es lo que significa es que no
importa el orden en que hagamos la
multiplicación ok o sea que las matrices
si cumplen la propiedad asociativa ahora
algo muy importante es que aquí no
estamos cambiando el orden de las
matrices porque aquí tenemos primero
naranja luego amarillo y luego morado y
de este lado tenemos también naranja
amarillo y morado lo único que estamos
cambiando es que de este lado primero
hacemos la multiplicación
la primera y segunda matriz y después a
lo que nos queda la multiplicamos por la
tercera matriz y de este lado primero
multiplicamos la segunda y la tercera
matriz y lo que nos queda lo
multiplicamos por la primera matriz ok
nada de cambiar de lugar las matrices
que ya vimos en el vídeo pasado que las
matrices nuevas son conmutativa y que no
las podemos cambiar de lugar bueno pero
este vídeo demuestra que las matrices si
son asociativas